I don't want any of you little [ __ ]
to take my [ __ ] I knew that what I did
was like very unorthodox like against
all the rules me and John get hit up a
lot by you know upcoming music producers
you know can you hear my beats if you'd
like any you know down to like
collaborate and you know the whole goal
for these guys is to get placement get
put on yeah which is yeah so basically I
had this idea I'm like well instead of
emailing me beats why don't we just link
up right so what I did was I created
this little event called pasty box where
aux Cuba I totally understand I got it
and so it's like come through to a
secrets let's put on seatbelts I'm not
trying to [ __ ] around for pass the offs
secret studio location 20 to 30
producers you register for the event and
you get to come to a studio and actually
you know plug in the aux cable and play
your beat for ill mind and you're there
with you know 20 to 30 other upcoming
producers that you've never met in that
city so it kind of works as like the
thing I've learned we're doing it is
like it works as an opportunity to play
me music but also to get them out of
their comfort zone you know these kids
are coming from like the basement with
their headphones on by themself with
like no interaction with anyone to now
being forced to play you know their
beats in front of 30 40 strangers on
like you
all Springer speakers and just putting
them on the spot so like if the
experience itself has been inspiring for
like them and me but also too just
seeing how many producers just wanting
okay they look up to you man I just
think you've done you know what happened
all of us like by the way every scar
micro Fame people don't get it like
anything anybody does somebody else
aspires to do like know like like it
just didn't work like that back in a day
I'm a businessman
didn't what a 41 year old white
businessman look like in culture 20
years ago right yeah same with producers
right like who was talking about
producers 30 years ago and the legacy
like you're gonna be laying down listen
to something 25 years I mean it's gonna
like in like the break we're just
talking about she'll be like I met him
up this like that's the [ __ ] that's how
much this [ __ ] this line I had people
were happy to be in life of four hours
because they were networking with each
other you know how crazy was that
through the sea in the city to the sea a
music people will a like what the [ __ ]
they're like is this for him yeah but no
it's interesting because like I think
these kids buy into the experience
thinking okay I'm gonna play my beats
for ill mind he's gonna like him enough
to collaborate with me of course and I
can get a placement and then they walk
away from the experience realizing that
it was more about breaking out of their
shell and really also getting a clearer
picture of seeing the the type of the
stuff that goes behind it right like wow
like I have a lot of work to do all
these all these guys are [ __ ] way
better than me
and then you have the few two or three
that get the most response and then
that's you know telling them that they
got something got something you know so
so wait you did one when yesterday last
night we're at 17 Hertz and it's to put
the ahead that ties in so this event is
it like a new thing but I think it all
started back in 2011 right so when I was
coming up I was a producer you know I
studied Pete Rock DJ Premier J Dilla you
know all the greats right and so there's
this culture and hip hop production
where you've never you're never supposed
to share your drum sounds where your
samples like you know like if they ask
you for you got a sample boy you don't
sample synergies so basically one day in
2011 this was around a time that I was
like working with
I was kind of Pleasant a little bit but
I was more of like the north the ground
producer where'd you grow up
Jersey where we work love it I grew up
in Edison office right there my business
is in Springfield my line story create
some real close yeah that's amazing
oh my god Rutgers yeah so how old are
you right now yeah 35 was the u.s. one
flea market still up or did they tear it
down by the time you went to Rutgers on
27 the movie theater was already there
right yeah cuz I saw eight-mile there
you know yeah I'm like Dana now no but
really they did cuz I grew up there
there was a fleet where that movie
theater is that big 101 101 that used to
be the u.s. one flea market oh that's
right that's right cut my chops and
baseball cards and toys and everything
that's where I learned it that's crazy
okay go ahead so one day in 2011 I'm
like I wonder if
you know there's producers out there
that want my sounds right so what to do
so at the time I'm like I'm like you
know let me put a collection together a
zip file of all the drum sounds that
I've made from scratch and used over the
years and just zip it where'd you put it
I uh I made a zip file and I put it on
my own website log sighs I would a
PayPal now button so I didn't think
anything of mine and uh you you just ask
for donations you didn't like people
take it if they want if they want to
give us all up it was I was charging you
were charging how much so 20 bucks yep
right here you go 150 sounds that's a
lot of [ __ ] a deal by now whatever
sorry I put it up whatever I didn't
think I he stepped away stepped away
woke up the next morning I saw like
three thousand extra dollars in my
PayPal account from sales so my holy
[ __ ] I see that alert did you have a
myspace of Twitter or Facebook where
were you at in myspace Twitter a little
bit yeah really
and then my block and that was it and
what about now Instagram Instagram yet
all that stuff like what are you most
focused on uh well Instagram I would say
Twitter Facebook I need to really be
born what about YouTube and snap YouTube
I'm just getting into and snap I'm just
kidding it's okay good good yeah but
most of it is Instagram I
yeah so anyway so I put that out and it
becomes this thing so then I'm like holy
[ __ ] this is real right there's
producers that want drum kits and so I
put volume two out and like dad did even
better and then I eventually migrated
into Shopify and then that just changed
the game for me and then just from there
on it just became a thing that's sure
now I think part of your business it's a
big part yes oh so it's at the point
where how do you sell it out meaning
like what do you what do you put out
what do you sell like 20 like how many
beads how much and you guys take a big
yeah we do is we use of course of course
of course and what do you guys say 20 50
how much do you take yeah producers have
different leverage I get it so the
interesting thing if that's why
attention matters man it's the only
thing that's all the whole world's data
see they just don't know it yet
I know no no no the world is d2c they
just don't know it yet
naturally from the junket stuff you know
I started a blog yeah I had the blog but
then I started a podcast which is just
you know it's called blab chat it's just
two hours every week of just music
production talk no [ __ ] yeah and so I
guess guess yeah right Leslie [ __ ] you
justice justice sorry there's all that
Grammy winning producers good for you
man I like that yeah I totally get him
in I didn't expect it you know and the
crazy thing is you know he met you know
very established producers like Grammy
winning producers and all these guys are
using the sound to so any new music
coming out you're always been here one
of my sounds in it it's [ __ ] crazy
this is nuts you know everything from
Bruno Mars's albums you know drinks and
album those are like my sounds because
everybody's incorporating some of that
stuff and do people know like well
people do people know like people didn't
eat people no no no right people like I
wouldn't know but like like no no
people matter that's a dream ass the
internet literally came along and
leveled the like not even leveled the
playing field gave gave the you know
what it did it ate up the distribution
of everything and then took nothing for
it and is paying out to groups of people
the biggest ballers who built on top of
it
Facebook Google right cuz they just
built it's basically like the Internet
is like the land and lie but Facebook
and Google did was like build the trains
and the planes but all the artists like
everybody with the IP the leverage
they're getting the dollars no more
middle middle men have to bring so much
value now which is great can't just sit
and be like cool right now that's it and
and and there's merit to it the people
that deserve it or get it and hasn't it
started you know what I noticed so
Marian I want your opinion sure I I've
noticed that every idea that I've had
where there's a drunk kid or the podcast
or whatever it was past the auks good
they're all things that I felt like
would end up being really fun to do and
and so my kind of philosophy I'm
adopting now is like if it's fun fun
it's probably you know why that happens
it's a it's a bigger macro situation
because it's fun you're willing to work
your face off and working your face off
is actually the gateway it's not the fun
the fun is the doorway that gets you to
put in the work that get you the results
because d-roc loves filming like the
24/7 nature of what he does is you know
is what so many kids want to film into
this but they don't want to it's not fun
enough for them you have to love it
you're the cost of entry now is you see
you understand you have to love like for
me building brands whether it's my own
brand brands for the people other things
the why it's so the only thing I give a
[ __ ] about that I'm willing to put in
the nineteen that it takes because the
problem is now with the internet like we
were just saying being the middleman and
everybody can play there's some kid in
Kansas City
is gonna put in the 19 right money put
in 20 and I don't want any I don't want
any of you little [ __ ] to take my [ __ ]
now what's amazing as though the biggest
thing I didn't know is that's some fun
but there's so much that all those
little [ __ ] that are gonna put in the
19 are gonna get theirs too and that
makes me happy yeah so I would say funs
a great gateway to fun is the precursor
to ridiculous amount of work which then
gets you there yeah right like I I do
that sneaker joint and then got in a car
and then took took a red-eye connecting
flight to Naples Florida the cell Hertz
rent-a-car got the business and then
flew back here for flights in 20 hours
you know ego getting gassed up with
2,000 people and then humility to be on
the plane [ __ ] like this like no PJ
like [ __ ] like putting in the grind
you know and I'm walking to be like
please can I help you like have the
humility to be like hey middle
management person in this rental car
company I'd really love your business
like being you know being able to to run
that gamut of ego and humility yeah fun
fun right fun
how often do you like balance that for
yourself how often is it fun and how
often is it not fun as long as its macro
fun I recognized micro [ __ ] exists like
Tuesday might suck March might suck 2018
might suck but macro it's fun
and when you get to that perspective you
stops you don't slow down when Tuesday
March her a year is [ __ ] and that's why
most people lose because they stop
either an hour into it not going well a
day a week a month got it so don't get
crippled like nothing's perfect every
second yeah the best things on earth
nothing's perfect
but having the understanding that macro
like what else would you rather be doing
exactly exactly and then you start
complaining about dumb [ __ ] right
meanwhile you're playing the game of
your dreams like little you growing up
in Newark if you would have showed this
now you and dr. Dre come on so that's it
you know what I mean so I'm perspective
out 10 years ago Buddha mad over the car
let's chop it up in the future now I'm
like boom let's put him on brown bags we
put out content Rick you turn yourself
into a media company you can always do
stuff always do stuff right so it's so
fun and it's so stakes are so high
stakes are so high the the people that
don't grab this [ __ ] by the neck over
the next two decades are gonna sit back
and be like what the [ __ ] was I thinking
how did I not see it
he he he took something that used to be
like held secret and he open sourced it
and created an API and so he's scaling
like a tech company got it put it like
that and that's what I'm doing the
business knowledge and the ideas I have
I'm sharing them with the world for free
this is stuff people used to sell this
is stuff a bunch of losers are selling
now and are giving you nothing there's a
stuff that I get paid tens of millions
of dollars for and I'm giving it these
[ __ ] for free if they're willing to
just sit on their ass and watch it a
little bit on YouTube like that is
incredible that's why I have power
that's why so many people show up
because I'm getting the best [ __ ] for
free
and everything ends up working their
Zenith podcast because of love love love
love love it's leverage yeah listen
everybody close their eyes and think
about the person that brings you the
most like happiness and love and and
value you're always trying to be around
that person and all those kids that came
to my event last night
all of them listen to my podcast they
have all the kits they have all that you
know they know all about me either
they're just any man and you know what
else is crazy how long you've been like
really hacking out like how long have
you been like thinking about it that way
you think um I won't say six years maybe
so you already know I don't think of you
any advice it's just one day at a time
you know for me this has been a really
interesting year because it did change
like it was like dude to do to do to do
it like I laugh every time a day like
this happens for Boyd I just sit there
and I'm like what does he think what
does he think because it really just
went you know like quick real quick
since December you know
but it's but it's 30 years as a minute
thirty years in the making we cannot
truly through what my thing is and you
know I think of myself much more like an
artist like when I think about me as a
businessman I think I'm a purebred I
think I've been doing it like the same
way people do sports and art they give
up on school and anything else that's
what I did but I did it for business and
nobody understood it back then I didn't
even understand it it just was like I
was drawn to the lot I felt like it was
a look you know I felt I was like a
fruit fly just like you know like I
couldn't help it like I understood my
logical brain was like schools you know
important but my heart Berlin and Seoul
was like it's hard yes Ari Shaffir you
gotta get out from Jersey it's right get
in there I know all about education so
yeah we [ __ ] why do you know did they
come ready born in Philippines they were
yes so like what the [ __ ] do we come
here for yeah I get it man I know this
is what every one of the kids that
everybody who's watching this on YouTube
right now every seventeen year old is
like they got the parents pressure and I
keep telling these kids I'm like you'd
better off being upset and having issues
now because if you listen to them and
become a lawyer and you wake up at 39
and you're miserable you're gonna
[ __ ] regret it and you're gonna blame
your parents for the rest of your life
and you guys don't have 30 years of bad
relationship instead of 30 months that's
true I see another issue too with like
you know with upcoming rappers and
producers where the grind and the
pressure
produces enough stress for them to not
even really enjoy what they're doing
that's right and so because they're not
yeah five years ago by you know I
thought they came into the game for the
wrong reasons right they came in for the
glitz and the glamour like the grind
doesn't feel like it doesn't like it
feels like a grind once in a while from
all of us yes
but it's not really yeah like what would
you what what else would you do like
what else would you do yeah like what
else could I possibly do then take
red-eyes you know how to be like what
else
[Music]